on apprend ce soir que six venant à peu
va faire le point demain là ça va être
demain matin sur la mission canadienne
en irak
à 10 heures demain matin céline durant
la période réservée aux déclarations
ministérielles le premier ministre
prononce un discours et s'accompagnera
ça le dépôt d'une motion pour prolonger
la mission canadienne en irak selon nos
sources le gouvernement proposera une
mission d'un an et proposera d'étendre
les frappes aériennes en syrie à l'heure
actuelle le personnel qui est sur place
je ne fais qu d'opérations qu en irak
toujours selon nos sources le
gouvernement veut un mandat d'un an plus
tôt de six mois pour éviter de se
retrouver en pleine période de
renouvellement durant une campagne
électorale les partis d'opposition déjà
reçu une partie de l'information ils
seront greffés là-dessus mercredi il y
aura débat jeudi
je vous rappelle qu'il ya à l'heure
actuelle six chasseurs cf-18 sur place
deux avions ravitailleurs
deux avions pas trop ici sans sommes
rattachés à la portion aérienne une
soixantaine de conseillers militaires
qui sont sur le terrain en irak pour
former les membres des forces irakiennes
j'ai eu une victime aussi voilà l'art
canadien merci beaucoup daniel on suivra
ça demain matin donc voiture avec